the winning flow was apparently inspired
by my best-selling children's book
Johnny The Walrus we must extend a
hearty congratulations to Fairbanks
School Board candidate Michael Humphrey
who won the prize for the best political
float at the city's golden Day Festival
parade and it is an enormous honor for
Mr Humphrey who won the award and also
for yours truly the float is a massive
walrus with the name Johnny emblazoned
on the front this should be a time of
celebration in Fairbanks celebration of
the Johnny The Walrus float indeed it
should be a time of Celebration across
the entire world Michael Humphrey's
Johnny The Walrus float has achieved the
highest honor ever awarded to a giant
inflatable walrus and yes we have kept
Daily records on that and so I know I
can say that